from coast to coast and across the uk
outrage at the sackings of 800 piano
ferry staff
[Music]
workers and supporters gathered in hull
in belfast
[Music]
and in dover where three quarters of the
staff live and worked among them a
couple dismissed after 31 years combined
service so worried about repercussions
that they asked us to speak anonymously
with their voices disguised the way they
came on board and locked us out of
everything literally made us feel like
criminals
once we then got the announcement and
everyone was devastated it was go to
your cabin get your belongings and get
off the ship take an envelope on your
way out and that was it
yesterday morning i woke up to a job
absolutely normal this morning we're
completely unemployed we're both
together we've got a mortgage a child at
home just bought a house last year do
you feel like you've got any choice but
to sign it no we'll have to sign the
unions are furious at the action p o has
taken and they believe firmly it is
illegal but they think it's action that
is likely to change the company's mind
rather than the court their argument is
if it can happen to them it can happen
to any employee
well we want pno to reverse their
decisions so that our people are put on
board running a safe
service we want our members jobs back
and we want them to change their
position they've ambushed our people
sacked them put them on the dole and
that's got to be reversed and if they
won't do it the government's got to do
it
lawyers say piano appear to be in clear
breach of employment law
piano should have gone through a
consultation process with
representatives with the union in
relation to the redundancies that set
out under statute by failing to do that
what they have done is unlawful
ministers have demanded an explanation
and urged piano to negotiate they've
taken one of the greatest names in
british maritime history the two
greatest initials p and o and turn them
into p off to their staff it's not
acceptable they need to get back around
the table and they need to deal with
this in the way that we would expect in
the 21st century
piano says it's acted in good faith to
save the company from collapse and says
they didn't consult because reaching
agreement would have been impossible
their former chairman told sky news the
redundancies were dreadful don't like it
at all but that's life isn't it the
company was in
in very poor financial situation and
they had to do this to save the ship
piano's holding company dp world is
owned by the uae government its chairman
mixes with british royalty and paid
shareholders 270 million pounds two
years ago
that's take two sleepy world also spends
tens of millions every year sponsoring
golf's european tour they say they're
committed to saving p o but the brand's
reputation may already be sunk paul
kelso sky news in dover